Welcome friends. Whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home,
it's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Dr.
Charlena Ariano. Now,
Dr. Ariano is a licensed psychologist,
founder of the Embodied Narrative
Framework,
and a powerful voice in the conversation.
About what it actually costs high
achieving women
to keep performing at the expense of
themselves.
Dr. Ariano, welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Thank you. I'm excited to be here and I'm
excited about the conversation.
Now,
listeners and viewers, you also need to
know that and is would you prefer that
I call you Charlena or Dr. Ariano?
You can call me Charlena.
Okay.
Charlene and I know each other from Mic
Drop Academy.
We are ~ speaker sisters and have shared a
lot.
We actually were both at ~ Indianapolis
recently at the Mic Drop Live convention.
That was so much fun, and it was such a
wonderful thing to be able to
get to see each other and
Hug one another after seeing each other on
Zoom calls for so,
so long. It was just fantastic.
So this is going to be so exciting because
we know each other on multiple levels.
So we're going to be able to just really
fold in all kinds of juicy stuff into this
conversation. So, Charlena, I want to
point out here that you have over
30 years of clinical and leadership
experience.
Now, this next part I find intensely
interesting,
and I can't wait to talk about this.
Your work helps women leaders understand
how nervous system patterns,
trauma-adapted achievement, and the
specific stress
of leading while also managing how their
race,
sexuality, or gender is being perceived in
the room as how's that shaping the way
they decide,
lead, and relate to success.
There's so much packed in there.
Is it there? Yes.
But it's
all good stuff. I mean, it's not usually
when I read some paragraphs,
some of them is like, this is boring.
I I just kind of push that off.
I don't even read this stuff. I just just
delete that stuff.
I just go right for the good stuff.
So let's just be where in that.
That's a lot. What why how is it that you
got so interested,
first of all, getting, you know,
your your doctorate in clinical psychology
and
Were
you interested in these areas before and
that's why you pursued your doctorate?
Or did you pursue your doctorate and then
along the way develop an interest
in these areas? Kind of share us,
share with us your your journey a little
bit about the how that happened,
how it unfolded.
Absolutely. So I didn't start there.
So I'll I'll I'll answer that question
really quickly.
I did not start where I am today.
~ you know, I think it's funny,
Dana. I don't know, I don't know if you
have this experience.
You know, sometimes sometimes you just
kind of you go down this path
and you you just know the next thing,
right? And I feel like that's what
happened for me.
What's interesting is people often say,
I mean, if you know a little bit about my
background,
they often say, Did you get into
psychology because of where you came from?
Like, you know, I came from a very
adverse background, you know, lots of
abuse and neglect and poverty.
And I said, no, they weren't connected at
all.
You know, I I had always been very,
very curious, very, very curious about
human behavior.
You know, what made people, what motivated
people,
what made them think the things that they
thought,
what made them feel the things that they
felt.
Very young, I can remember being four and
and l watching people very intently.
So that's what got me into psychology.
I didn't even know what psychology was.
So
I was very curious about that.
And then what happened was, ~ you know,
I thought I was gonna, you know,
you you go through, you know, being a a
young girl or,
you know, a teenage you know, like a
preteen,
and it's like I want to be a doctor.
And I thought I was gonna be a doctor
because everybody wants,
you know, you wanna be what, a doctor,
a police officer, a fireman, whatever,
right? ~
Right.
and so what hap that's what I thought I
was gonna do.
I thought I'm gonna be a pediatrician.
And then I took in my ~ junior year of
high school,
I think it was my junior year high school,
I had a psychology class and it was like
This is it. I mean, I knew immediately.
I want to do this for a living.
How do I do it? So I basically at that
moment I made the decision.
I went straight through undergrad to
graduate school,
got my PhD, had my PhD ~ by the time I was
29.
And I got it, I did very traditional
things.
I worked with families, I worked with
families and children.
And worked in very high-intense situations
because I'm a very high-intense person
and I loved it. And
Mm-hmm.
I did it for a while and I got really
burnt out and I stopped doing it.
And so things evolved. And so what
happened was,
and this is gonna be perfect for this
particular podcast,
Dana, because I'm gonna make the
connection here.
~ you know, we are often, we are often a
version of ~ we who we are.
~ we are a version of our perfect client,
right? And it could be a previous version
of who we are.
~ and that's who we serve because we know
it intimately.
So when I talk about being a high
achieving person or woman
in these settings and having to manage
perceptions,
I lived that. And so I have that,
and the whole nervous systems,
the whole nervous system perspective.
really actually came from my own healing
journey.
You know, being, you know, so think about
you got to remember,
you have to turn the dial back,
you know, the clock back 30 plus years.
And I was in rooms that I was the only
person of color.
You know, I would be and I was often,
you know, I was in the closet for a very
long time.
I I actually did not you're gonna laugh at
this.
I did not come out of the closet until
2024.
And so being in
Okay.
a room, being in a room where,
you know, my last name and the color of my
skin would change the dynamic.
Like I could walk into a room and feel the
tension and feel like,
my God, I don't, you know, you you
question it.
You question your reality. You question,
do I not belong here? Did I not do I not
deserve a seat at the table?
You ha and you become very vigilant about
those things and you start
to notice whether they're micro.
aggressions or outright overt,
you know, kinds of aggressions.
So I'm gonna stop there. I can
So let me I've got
already I've got questions. So cause I'm
trying also to think of
of the listeners and and the and the
viewers.
And for those people who have not
experienced what
it feels like to be a minority in the
minority group.
Cause you talk about
Mm-hmm.
walking into a room and you can just feel
the tension.
Mm-hmm.
If there's someone listening that they're
like,
they want to know, they want to be more
empathetic,
they want to be more understanding,
but they haven't experienced that.
Mm-hmm.
What can you share with them? Like if
hypothetically,
if they were in a room, let's say they
were not in a per in a minority group
and they were sitting in a room,
Mm-hmm.
what is what are some things, some
examples of some behaviors that
you would observe or words that or phrases
that would be said or something,
anything that come to mind at all that
that I th you know, my the listeners are
like,
my gosh, am I doing that? Am I saying
that?
I don't even know that I'm I have that
look on my face or I don't even know that
I'm saying these phrases that could be
hurtful to someone in a minority group.
Right. Yes.
I wanna take just
a moment to just kinda hover over that and
kind of bring that that that illumination
to that area.
Right, absolutely. And and I do want to
share this,
Dana, because I think it's important also,
is something to consider and and the
listeners considering this as well is,
you know, I'm I'm like any other human,
you know, I've grown and I've evolved and
I didn't understand at the time what
was happening. I understood after.
Like looking back, it was like,
~
you know, those kinds of things.
So I'll give you examples. And I think
part of it is you also have
to remember this is intergenerational.
So this isn't just me, but you know,
also being in a household and hearing
about my father's experiences,
hearing about my grandmother's
experiences,
and also the time. So you got to think
about the time,
the era. The era was you fit in,
you fit in, you don't stand out,
you know.
The the era was, there was almost this
flavor of you're,
you're not, you don't belong here.
You're not supposed to be here.
So it's almost like you have to ask
permission,
which it creates this very subtle dynamic.
But I'll give you examples. I'll give you
examples that are more subtle,
and I'll give you examples that aren't so
subtle.
Okay, fantastic.
So examples
of something being subtle would be you
would walk into a room.
Okay, so here I am, I'm a you know,
I can talk about graduate school or even
postgraduate school.
I'm a PhD, I'm a doctor. I would walk into
a room and the moment I would walk into
the room, the room would stop,
like literally stop, like the activity
would stop,
the conversations would stop, and
everybody's ~ gaze would look at go to me.
And it would be silence for about 30,
45 seconds, which was weird. So that was
weird.
That's a long time, yeah.
That
was a long time. So that would be an
example.
Or another example that would be subtle is
you could have conversation going
on around the table. And the moment that I
would add something,
and it was different. So if it was a white
counterpart,
there was interaction, there was back and
forth,
there was this flow in conversation.
As soon as I would
Add something, there would be silence.
Like it didn't, it wasn't received.
And so those are subtle. Here's
Okay. Okay.
less subtle situations. Things like,
wow, you're really smart. And you feel
like there's supposed to
be something that comes after that they
don't say.
Like you're really smart for a Latina,
you know, or something like that.
They wouldn't say that, but you
Mm-hmm.
knew that's what was coming next.
So, or or I would get,
Wow, you are really articulate.
It is, you know, or they would say,
you're really articulate for English being
your second language.
So they'd make an assumption. And I would
I would correct them.
I'd say, well, first of all, I I am not
fluent in Spanish.
English is not my second language.
It's my first language. So things like
that.
Or they would say, ~ so where are you
from?
Where did you come from? And I would say,
Well, I came from here.
No, but really,
Ha ha.
where did you come from? Well,
I'm I was born here, Denver, Colorado,
born here. Well, how about your parents?
my dad was born born in New Mexico.
Well, what about before him? And I was I
Gosh.
would be like, ~ my family's been here for
about 300 years.
How about yours? So, you know,
Yeah, good greet.
it'd
be things like that. So you you would get
the sense that you whether it
was overt or covert, you got the sense
that you weren't.
quite welcomed or embraced.
Mm-hmm.
And so
that just became part of my nervous
system.
It was, I would walk into rooms and
eventually I got tired.
I'll be, I'll be really frank with you,
Dana. It was like I'm tired of doing this.
I'm tired of being the token brown person.
I'm tired of being the token queer person.
And I decided to stop participating.
And so I actually got out of the
professional world probably how long?
Let's see, I was probably about ~ I have
to do the math,
2003 when I said I'm done.
with it. So 2003, I would have been just
under 40.
I think under 40. ~ am I doing the math
right?
Yeah. You know, and I just had enough.
I just I had enough of navigating that.
Like I spent more energy navigating,
do I belong here? Do I have credibility?
You know, those kinds of things.
So that those are examples.
Those are fantastic, by the way.
You know, and I'm thinking about you're
talking about
the nervous system involvement.
Because I'm imagining that we have
listeners and viewers that might
be experiencing now what you've just
described that you went through some years
ago.
And they might hear us talking about
nervous system involvement and not really
know.
what that means exactly. So I'm wondering
if you could take a few moments
and for those people that are maybe facing
some of the things that
you just described and they're they're
going through it now in some kind of way,
what how would they know if their nervous
system what does it feel like?
Describe it 'cause they might be feeling
it and they don't even know that's what
it is.
Exactly. Exactly. And I want to preface it
with this,
Dana, because you you you you started our
conversation with,
you know, kind of, were you always
interested this or interested in this,
or did you happen to get here?
And I I talk about getting here and I look
at my own my own trajectory,
my own path, my own evolution,
my own healing. And you know, because of
my background and because of
my own healing trajectory, ~ I was living,
like I was living.
you know, the experience of trauma.
Like I was living the ~ the
hypervigilance.
I was living the chronic bracing and
activation.
And because of that, it I was very curious
about it.
I mean, my own healing required me to
understand what was happening in my body.
Mm-hmm.
Because what I learned and what I
discovered is that,
you know, like, okay, we're both
therapists,
right?
And you know, I I I you know, I do believe
that therapy is helpful.
And I also believe that therapy is
limited.
And the way that I think therapy is
limited is there's a lot of talking
involved.
There's a lot of verbal processing,
there's a lot of cognitive processing,
but what's not happening is there's not
processing on the nervous system level.
So it doesn't go into those deeper layers.
And so I became very interested in.
my gosh, I'm recognizing in my body that
there are things that are happening that
I wasn't consciously aware of until I
stopped and paid attention.
So here are some things that we can say
this is nervous system stuff.
~ I, as early as probably about five years
ago,
I was doing something very mundane.
I was putting, you know, my laundry away.
I was in my bedroom. I mean, it was such a
profound experience that I
can tell you exactly what was happening.
And I stopped and I went, my, my goodness,
I'm bracing. Like I am read, I'm ready for
impact.
Like there's nothing happening.
And and so I tell you, you know,
this is I'm 55 years old. Okay.
I have spent more of my life in safety.
Then I had not in safety. Okay.
Yet my nervous system was still stuck
in this place of I'm waiting for something
bad.
I'm waiting for something bad.
I'm whether, you know, whether it was
physical abuse,
whether it was, you know, perpetrators and
being in a,
you know, in a in a place, in places I
shouldn't have been.
And here I am, 55, totally safe,
nothing's going on. And my body,
I mean, I'm literally like this.
I could feel the tension. And it was like,
there's no reason to be bracing.
So that was basically my first,
like it was the window open to this idea
of the nervous system because
I had done decades of therapy,
like tons of therapy. And it was like it
still had not touched this.
It was like this was a different reality.
Mm-hmm.
And
it spoke a different language.
And so getting back to your question for
the listeners is how do how can you tell?
There's lots of ways that you can tell
when you're activated.
It can be like what I just described,
bracing. And you can you can recognize,
my God, my body's tight. Like I'm,
I'm like, and you can see me moving.
It's like you're ready for impact.
You're literally ready for impact.
That's an example. Another example is,
you know, ~ people will often say,
this is just anxiety.
This is just anxiety. And something to
consider,
and again, my being a psychologist,
and I know you'll appreciate this as a
therapist,
Dana, is anxiety is an emotional
experience.
You know, we label it, we label it.
But what's underneath anxiety,
and the reason we call it anxiety,
is because something's happening in our
body and our mind immediately labels it.
Well, we as Americans go into go into
thought.
Very quickly. We go into mind very
quickly.
We go into stories and labels and all that
stuff.
We we bounce out of the body pretty
quickly.
So anxiety, for example, well,
it's an activated nervous system.
What's going on? Usually our heart's
racing.
Usually we have shallow breath.
Sometimes we get tunnel vision.
Sometimes we get ringing in the ears.
And we call that anxiety. Well,
that's a nervous system response to
threat.
And it it all those things that I just
described.
is an activated nervous system that is
ready to fight or run.
We have that's all the things we need.
You know, we get tunnel vision because we
just need to see in front of us.
You know, our heart races, we need more
blood.
You know, sometimes we get the shallow
breath because we don't have
the luxury of taking a deep breath because
we're gonna take off,
kind
Mm-hmm.
of thing. So so those would be examples,
you know. Like if you think about it in
day-to-day work or day-to-day living,
you know, you're gonna find that,
you know, you're chronically, you know,
you're chronically.
Just moving at this really fast pace,
and your men, your mind is racing,
and your heart's racing, and you're you're
sweaty,
or you know, you're shallow br you have
shallow breath.
Those are really common things.
Now that's activated and ready to go,
right? That's the go mechanism.
Some people have the opposite,
and it's the collapse. It's the I can't do
this.
It's the I don't, I don't want to,
I don't want to move. I don't want to get
out of bed.
I don't.
I'm resigned, you know, nothing's gonna
help anyway.
And there's there's literally a bodily
kind of body,
you know, biology kind of neurology kind
of,
you know, ~ under under current to that.
So, you know, I I didn't believe this
until probably maybe
10 years ago. I always thought everything
started with thought.
It doesn't.
It starts with the nervous system.
The nervous system is online before we
have a co any conscious thought about it.
And it's running the show. It's running.
It absolutely
is. It's fascinating when you see the
research.
Mm-hmm.
The that that emotional part of our brain,
that animal part of our brain is so much
faster and
yeah.
so much stronger than the neocortex that
has the the you know the logic
Yo, yes. Yes. Yes.
and the reasoning. I
mean. So let me ask you this for because
I'm thinking as I'm listening
to you describe these symptoms.
I'm thinking about people that have been
in this,
lodged in it for so long and they they
haven't realized what it is,
they haven't really gotten help,
and it's become chronic. One one symptom
that
I'm thinking of ~ is the is the TMJ.
Хай джа.
So I'm kinda and how many clients,
you know, come in and say, you know,
I've got I grind and I clench my teeth and
because of that I've got,
you know, so I was kinda wondering from
your experience and from your perspective,
what kind of symptoms do people have when
they've just dealt with this
for so long and they haven't known what it
is and now it's chronic in their
Yeah.
body?
Great question. So typically what you'll
find with a chronic or
the chronicity of this is you are going to
see things like TMJ.
You're going to see chronic headaches.
You're going to see ~ chronic fatigue,
~ sleep problems, ~ oftentimes chronic
pain.
Let me think if there's others that I can
think of.
~ Digestive issues.
are often really common because again,
if you're in a chronic state of
activation,
I mean part of the biological process that
get that is involved with being activated
is we have adrenaline being dumped into
our system.
Well, we have to, we have to process it
goes through our GI system.
So people will have things like chronic
upset stomach,
or they might have, you know, lower GI
issues.
And, you know, they think that there's
something medically wrong with them when
there's not. This is just a chronic
activated nervous system.
Now, I don't want, I don't want to
disregard the possibility that somebody
could
have some medically something medically
wrong,
but a lot
Sure.
of times people that are dealing with what
we call chronic stress,
you know, what we don't talk about is
chronic stress is.
Basically, an activated nervous system
that never turns off,
Mm-hmm.
which we're not designed for. Our bodies
are not designed for chronic activation.
We are designed for spikes. We're designed
for threat,
take care of it, come back to baseline.
In our culture, and especially with the
women that I work with,
the the the very, very kind of driven,
high-achieving types of people,
they're chronically on.
Chronically, they don't shut down.
They don't shut it off. And and you can
tell,
you can see it.
Mm. So what would someone if if there
if there's women out there that are
listening and they're thinking,
my gosh, that is me? And I mean,
and we know, let's I want to say first
before I go on with my next question,
like you said, we know there are medical
issues that people have,
right? But if I'm not mistaken,
the research also indicates that stress,
anxiety,
Activated
nervous system that just goes on and on
exacerbates just about all the stuff,
whether you have GERD, whether you have
Mm-hmm.
IBS, you know,
these kinds of things that the ulcerative
colitis,
these
Mm-hmm.
issues that people struggle with,
they can have those physical diagnoses,
but the chronic stress, the chronic
activation of the nervous system
is going to make all of that worse.
Am I re am I recalling the research
correctly?
Well, or
it the question is, i i is there a chicken
egg here,
you know, kind of thing. It's like,
is the chronic stress causing these
ailments?
I mean, I don't know if we'll ever know,
but there's a good I mean, there's
definitely you can define processes that
would
make sense that it would point to that.
You know, like GI issues. I mean,
you know, I mean, none of us have to
really think about this really hard.
Any of us that have been really,
really stressed, you get an upset stomach.
Well, there's a reason you get an upset
stomach.
You know, it's not just it it's not
psychosomatic.
There are biological things happening in
your body to prepare
you to protect yourself that that cause
stomach upset.
Now, what happens over time? You know,
like if this is chronically going on,
what eventually happens in the GI system?
Or what ends up happening in the jaw
because you're bracing all the time
and waiting for impact?
You know, or you know, the headaches and
those kinds of things.
So again, the question is, is it an
exacerbation or is it causal?
You know, and it could be both.
Could be both. So
Absolutely.
you talk about high performing women,
which I must say, we
Mm-hmm.
are both, we both fit into this category.
Yes. yes. Yes.
Let's just throw that out there.
the so the hyper and I want to talk about
women in particular,
because I've I've interviewed men and
their perspectives,
and they would agree as well that they
face different things.
Women, we we each face different issues,
and lots of times women are having to deal
with
So many, so many spinning plates,
professional plates being a lot of them,
but also with their partners, with their
families,
with the expectations of women in our
culture.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
And then you
have you have women who are high
performing.
And
Mm-hmm.
so that just like shoves them out to the
forefront because then
you have people around them that are going
to rely on them and want them,
expect them to show up, expect them to do
these,
these kinds of things.
So for these women that are listening
right now and they're thinking,
they're describing me. They are describing
me.
I have those things. What am I supposed to
do about it?
What are some steps? If they're listening
and they're thinking,
that's that's me, what would you say like
would be three,
three things that you would recommend that
they do to begin the process
of pulling out of that?
Mm-hmm. Th that's a great those that's a
really good question,
Dana. I think there's different layers or
levels to it.
You know, we are it's interesting.
~ there there's several things that I've
I'm thinking of all at once.
Is when you look at the gender
differences,
when you look at the difference between
men and women,
women
Will women seem to have bigger challenges
with this.
And I think the reason why is we have been
socialized very differently.
So I mean, we can look at this from an
evolution per perspective.
I mean, if we want to look at if we want
to look at cavemen up to now,
our roles have been pretty defined
according to gender.
Men were responsible for two things get
food and protect.
That was it.
And it it was it was basically one track.
Gotta go out and do this. Okay.
Women, you know, from the beginning of
humankind,
we have been socialized to manage lots of
things all at the same time.
You know, manage needs of all these
different people at the same time.
And we've been very, we've been very
outwardly focused in that regard.
Men tend to be on tracks. I often joke
about this with,
I do a lot of couples work.
And you know, when when husbands and wives
in particular are kind of going
to battle here, you know, one of the
things that I talk about is men
and women have different brains.
I mean, they have different brains,
and it has to do with evolution because
men just need to be on these tracks.
I need to go get food. I need to go work.
It's just a track. Women and you know,
or or and women are more likely to think
in webs.
Everything is connected and attached.
Well, what what does that how does that
translate?
Into terms of stress, men are really good
about compartmentalizing.
I get on my train track, I take the train,
the train leaves the station, nothing else
exists around but this track
to the destination. And women are are
very,
I mean, they're aware of everything that's
happening,
happening around them. And again,
it has a lot to do with socialization.
So let's go back to this idea of,
well, what do I do with this?
You know, we often have this, you know,
this very kind of superficial idea of,
you just need to take care of yourself.
Go get your nails done. Go go get a
massage or you know,
take some new time. Well, first of all,
high achieving women are probably not
going to do that because they're like,
go, let's go, let's go, let's go,
right? And and so what seems more in reach
is gonna sound really weird.
But one of the things that I think is
really important that none of us do,
none of us have been taught to.
We're not shown in our culture to do this.
And that is nervous system resets several
times a day.
Several times a day. And it takes five
minutes or or less.
Sometimes it's seconds. But the idea of
before you go into something
or you're leaving something or there's a
transition or you recognize you're
a little activated to be able to stop and
just go,
okay, I'm gonna just sit and I'm gonna
just notice what's happening in my body.
And let's say I'm going, okay,
I can feel this swirling feeling in my
chest.
I'm just gonna sit with a swirling
feeling.
I don't have to fix it. I don't have to
understand it.
~ you know, I don't have to make it go
away,
just be with it. What happens?
And what you'll find is as you create
focus into that place,
just it just starts to change.
The energy changes. And what'll happen is
you stay with it,
it can be anywhere from 45 seconds to a
few minutes.
And you will feel a reset. You will feel,
~ all of a sudden I just felt like this,
it's it almost feels like a peaceful
feeling,
like it's just, it's just neutral.
We
Yeah.
never do that. So we're always
accumulating.
We're never starting at zero. We're
starting at 50.
We're starting at 75, you know,
and and because of that, we're always just
this close to going over an edge.
Yeah.
And everybody understands what that means,
that edge.
You're right. my God, I'm gonna go off the
edge.
I'm gonna lose my mind. We know what that
feels like.
And the reason we have that is because we
never reset.
We never reset.
Mm. I love this so much because and I know
we're getting close to out of time,
but I wanted to point out that I've
started doing the the Pomodoro time method
where
I would do something. I would literally
have to set my clock because I work like
I like I drive on the freeway.
And here's how I drive on the freeway.
I'm gonna get in the left lane and I
Right. I go straight to the left lane.
Right. The right lane is for people that
drive the speed limit.
The left lane is for crime. I'm gonna get
in the left lane and I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna go eighty five and I
don't want anybody in my F and way.
Get out of my F and way. If you're gonna
drive
Right? Yes.
slower, that's the right lane,
that's for you. So and I go and so that's
the way I work because I very much enjoy
what I'm doing, but I will push,
push, push, push, push, push. And if I
don't,
if I don't set a timer.
on my phone to do exactly what you're
describing,
to have the that five minutes or that 10
minutes to reset.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
I mean,
by one o'clock, two o'clock, three o'clock
comes around,
I'm just, I'm ready to climb the walls
because my
Mm-hmm.
whole system, like you're describing,
is just like I mean, it's just revved
Mm-hmm.
up. It reminds me of the RPMs,
like if you're sitting in a car and you
Yes.
have it in park.
Mm-hmm.
But you press
the accelerator and how the RPMs go and
stays up like that.
Yeah, yeah. Yes.
That's what my whole body feels like.
If I don't stop and do exactly but when I
do stop,
when I hear my alarm and I get up and I
walk away,
and I walk up and
Okay.
down the hall and I take some deep breaths
and I allow myself to kind
of move away from it and allow my body to
calm down and do exactly what you're
describing. It is a d I mean, it makes a
huge difference.
It does. It does. And it's it it requires
so so little time.
The thing that I often hear with the women
I were,
I don't have time. I don't have time.
I don't have time. I don't have time to do
this.
And I say to them, first of all,
you can do this in 30 seconds.
So you have 30 seconds. I said,
secondly, it's worth it. Because do you
want to lose your shit by the end
of the day and then regret it?
Because typically what's going to happen
is it's going to come out.
We're gonna hurt somebody. We're gonna
hurt somebody with our words,
our energy, our tone. And now we're
dealing with regret,
guilt, and regret, right? Which are not
good feelings.
And so a lot of times this is like I I
will often tell my clients,
this is like brushing your teeth.
If you don't brush your teeth,
you're gonna lose your teeth to cavities
and decay.
I said, You you've got it, this is
hygiene.
This is another form of hygiene.
It's a it's a nervous system.
hygiene that you do throughout the day.
And it's in and you can do it for 30
seconds.
You can do it between meetings.
You got a meeting, shut the door for a
second,
take a minute, get reset, and then go to
the next one.
I
love this so much and because it's
practical,
it's doable and
Mm-hmm. It does.
it works.
It does work. It does.
I mean it's
it does. It absolutely does. It makes a
huge difference.
Now I wanted to say before we go,
I wanted to bring up you you had a second
book called The Last Dance.
And
Mm-hmm.
then you said you have a forthcoming book.
And I love this title. Terrible Gifts
Finding the Light in
the Darkest of Places. Do you want
Mm.
to tell the listeners and the viewers
about your books before we tell them where
Yes. Yes.
they can go to get more of you?
Yes, absolutely. So the terrible gifts is
currently in the publication process.
We are literally editing it. As a matter
of fact,
after I hop off this call, I'm with my
editor.
and you know, again, as I had mentioned,
and and I I'm sure many of us can
understand this,
is usually our zone of genius,
usually the thing that we do in the world,
what we bring into the world is the result
of our life experience,
right? And so I'm not any different in
that regard.
So terrible gifts is my memoir.
And it's based on my ~ my life story,
my childhood. And so part of the reason
that I'm very much into
the nervous system and embodied narrative
is because I've lived this life
of understanding the impact of trauma and
what happens,
the impact of trauma on your nervous
system,
the impact of trauma on what you who you
believe you are,
what you believe the world is about,
what you think you deserve. And,
you know.
I I basically take the reader through,
you know, my, you know, rise from the
ashes.
And I've had a few of those, by the way,
but my
Yeah.
biggest one was at the age of 34,
where I was like, I don't know if I'm
going to get through this.
And, you know, recognizing that,
~ you know, I needed to go back.
I needed to go back and and and and heal
and process the trauma.
The terrible gifts, the reason I came up
with that title.
Was that for a very long time I I ran from
my my my past.
Like I was like, I don't I don't want
anybody to know about this.
There was a lot of shame involved.
I felt, I believed that I was this person
despite this.
And what I realized was I am this person
because of this.
And so that's where the terrible gifts
came from is this idea that,
you know, you think about think about a
diamond,
for example. A diamond is created through
compression,
like a massive amount of pressure.
And we as humans, it's the same kind of
experiences.
You know, they often say, you know,
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
Well, I also believe that the the hard the
hard stuff that we go through cultivates.
Who we become and what we share in the
world.
So that's the Terrible Gifts book.
The last dance has to do with
intergenerational trauma.
So it's through the lens of my
relationship with my father.
So my father was the perpetrator.
My father was very physically abusive,
a very violent man. And he passed in 2012.
And it was after he passed, it's
interesting.
I tell people I have a better relationship
with my father,
with him being dead.
Than I did when he was alive. And what I
recognized is I got perspective,
and I recognized my father had a lot of
trauma,
and my father was reacting from trauma,
and his father had trauma. And so,
what it basically is the reason the book
is called The Last Dance
is I've stopped the cycle. Like it his
dance with me was the last one.
And
Mm-hmm.
I've changed that trajectory for my
family.
You know, like my son, my son has not
experienced.
any of what I experienced, you know,
with it with regard to intergenerational
trauma.
So that's what the book is about,
the second book.
That
that sounds fantastic. And I did wanna I
did wanna kind of float out there because
I know ~ talk about boundaries because you
know,
the queen of boundaries and I'm
Yes.
thinking for those people if you you know,
if there's listeners out there or viewers
that are in a current relationship,
you know, we can understand if the i if
the relationship is dysfunctional,
whether it's you know, a parent,
let's just say parent because that's what
you brought up with your dad,
Mm-hmm.
I also had a very dysfunctional
relationship with my mother,
and she has also
Passed on. It's like, yes, when they're
deceased,
you no longer have to deal with a
dysfunction.
But if if it but if someone is still
living,
you can understand that they were
traumatized and you can feel bad that they
they
were traumatized. But there has to be some
kind of boundary that you're
not allowing. Like you said, the last
stance,
it stops with me. I'm not going to allow
this.
I understand what caused it, but
Mm-hmm.
that cause wasn't me.
And
I'm not going to allow that current
ongoing abuse,
dysfunction to continue. And that's where
kind of boundaries come into play
Mm-hmm.
came in for me and for other people that
I've talked to as well,
like before they before they pass away.
It's like you can't you can't allow that
to continue,
even though you understand why.
Right, right, exactly, exactly.
Yes. And you know, I often say I I I've
thought about this in terms
of my own journey because at this point in
my life,
and it wasn't always like this,
Dana, is that at this point in my life I
am mostly estranged from my family.
~ and the only ~ couple of people that I
have any if I I won't even call
it a relationship.
~ because a relationship, you know,
implies reciprocity, you know.
~ but it's a very very, very distant.
And it wasn't always that way.
I think I spent much of my life,
and I will often talk about this with my
clients,
is you have to balance your desire for
connection.
And your protection. It's like those two
things.
And it's a dance. It's a dance.
You know, I and I did that dance.
There were times where the connection was
up higher and the protection was lower.
And then it went like this, you know,
because ultimately, at you know,
at the end of the day, Dana, we are
tribal.
We are pack animals. We we need families.
And families can be chosen, they don't
have to be be blood related.
Yet we have that in our DNA. We need to be
in tribes.
And so
I don't, you know, when I work with my
clients and in my own process,
I'm very respectful for their need to
connect to be connected and to have tribe,
and also for them to decide what's my
level of protection that I need and how,
you know, is it possible to do both?
Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
You know, I know with my mother,
for example, what she passed, she actually
just passed in February,
and I was estranged from her. You know,
I I checked in with her about once every
six months to make sure she was okay,
and that was it. That was it. And that was
necessary.
That level of protection was necessary.
Mm-hmm. Totally get that. And I know
there's listeners and viewers that totally
understand that as well. So for people
that want to know more about you,
they want
Mm-hmm.
to access you more, they want to engage
with you more,
find out what more you have to offer.
I have drsharlina.com.
Yes.
And the spelling of your name,
I'm going to say it out loud, but y'all
will see in the show notes.
But it's C-H A R L E A N E A.
It's it's a it's a different spelling.
It's a very unique spelling.
Very unique.
Yes. So I wanna make sure y you get get it
spelled right.
But that'll be in the show notes.
That's no problem. But that's where you
want them to go to be able to Okay.
Yes, that would be the best
place because then they can find
everything else on on my website.
Awesome. Charlena, this has been I knew it
would be.
I knew it would be a blast. I
Yeah.
knew we would have so much to talk about.
And we have so much more, but I know we
have thirty minutes.
And ~ I know. And
I mean, we we get along so well and we've
had our time with the academy.
And so I really appreciate you being
willing to spend your precious time
to come on Phoenix and Flame and share
your your experience and
be transparent about your, you know,
your your past and and sharing your wisdom
with the listeners and the viewers.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you, Dana. It's been fun and I'd
love to come back if you want
to talk about other things. I I could love
to talk about more trauma.
I love trauma. Trauma and pain.
~ we could talk
about we could talk about that stuff.
my gosh. Viewers, listeners, I know that
you have heard multiple things
today that you're thinking, ~ my gosh,
I know a friend, I know a relative,
I know a coworker who needs to hear
exactly what Dr.
Charlena has to say. Take this podcast
episode.
Copy and paste the link, send it in a
text,
send it in the email, post it on your
favorite social media sites so we
can grow our Phoenix and Flame community
and let people know you are not alone.
Right.
I hope your day has been great.
I hope the rest of it is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.